this is the first time I'm posting
anything online about this I'm a 31 year
old woman married and I recently moved
back in with my parents due to moving
back to the town I grew up my husband
and I are taking our time looking for
our own place due to wanting something
nice in the area that's usually hard to
find this story takes place in my
parents house starting back 10 years ago
a description of the house for a bit of
context it's a two-story brick and stone
house in city limits but still
surrounded by nothing but woods you have
to go through a garage that leads into
the kitchen with the first bedroom to
your left past the kitchen is the main
living room and to the right is the hall
that's very open in this area you'll
find the main dining room and the second
living area but if you continue straight
you will see the staircase to your left
and even further straight on is my
parents bedroom and bathroom going up
the stairs you'll come to the third
living area with two sets of French
doors side-by-side that lead to the
outside balcony going straight then a
sharp left leads you to the other three
bedrooms and two bathrooms this is where
the story takes place the first time I
stepped foot into this house I
immediately felt off like something just
wasn't right I felt a presence but I
didn't know what or who it was I brushed
it off thinking I was just reading too
much into it I continued to feel this
for the next couple of years and because
of this I didn't much enjoy visiting
them my parents liked to gamble a lot
back then so they would ask me to
babysit my baby brother and sister one
day on the weekend my boyfriend now
husband loved them so he would always
babysit with me the first few times I
really didn't pay attention to the
feeling I would get because we would be
busy playing or eating with the kids
after that things kind of chilled out
and we would end up watching movies
until it was time for us to go to bed
now my husband is a freak of nature it's
like he falls asleep the second his eyes
are closed me on the other hand it takes
me forever to get comfortable enough to
wind down my mind I also don't sleep
well even when I finally do get to sleep
this night was the first time I saw and
heard something in this brand-new house
in this room the bed is facing the
doorway but not directly in front of it
with the double doors open you can see
the front of the staircase and all the
way down the hallway as long as the
light is on that is this night only one
of the hallway lights was on I was lying
in bed with the TV on but the volume
down low so I could hear if one of the
kids called me I was almost asleep when
I heard one of my siblings coming down
the stairs I opened my eyes a bit and
waited for them to get to the bottom but
they never did I didn't think anything
of it I closed my eyes and began to
drift off again a few minutes later I
heard it again so I opened my eyes and
waited but again they never got to the
bottom this time i sat up and listened a
bit spooked but nothing I couldn't
handle
I got a bit nervous but still I went to
check to see if they were there and
maybe they were scared to go all the way
down or something no one was there
confused and thinking I must have been
dreaming I went back to bed this time
closing one of the double doors it was a
few hours later around 2:30 a.m. when I
felt like someone was very near me as if
they were standing next to the bed right
in front of me usually when I opened my
eyes I would see the green glow of the
alarm clock on the bedside table but
this time I saw nothing it was
pitch-black I couldn't even see the
hallway light on and the TV had turned
off on its own I felt like I couldn't
move I was awake now and scared to my
bones I was finally able to call out my
husband's name loud enough to wake him
he reached over and turned on the light
and right then the scared feeling went
away and I was able to move I freaked
out and started crying I couldn't begin
to explain to him what happened because
even if I had he didn't believe in those
things so I told him I was having a
nightmare and asked him to go check on
the kids when he came back he said the
kids were fine and got back in bed with
a light on I was able to fall back to
sleep
but it took me forever
the next day I told my mom about what
had happened and that's when she told me
she had been hearing footsteps on the
stairs at night and even saw someone
standing by the door at times she didn't
tell anyone because she didn't want to
scare the kids this is when she told me
what she had done she wanted to know
what was going on in her house so she
went and bought a voice recorder one day
she decided to use it and went upstairs
while everyone was gone she asked your
typical questions of who is here what do
you want and why are you here and then
said you have passed away and need to go
into the light you were not welcome here
the next day she decided to leave the
recorder in one of the bedrooms upstairs
it was recording for about four hours
while she was out running errands I
asked if she had checked it and to my
surprise she said she was too afraid to
listen to it alone I wanted to listen to
it off we went to the computer and began
listening to it after it was uploaded
during the four hours she was gone
you could hear something clicking or
tapping sounds of a drawer opening and
closing but we weren't sure then we
listened to the part where she was
asking questions now you could hear a
sound that resembled a fan or maybe
static throughout the whole thing
so some sounds were indistinguishable
but the one sound we did hear chilled us
to the core when she asked what do you
want it gave us an answer
I'm changing my brother's name for this
but the answer was Jamie it didn't
answer any other questions except for
that one
I cried immediately Jamie wasn't having
night terrors for no reason
something was there for him every night
we soon asked a friend to cleanse the
house for a long time everything's been
ok my brother stopped having night
terrors my mom was able to sleep
comfortably and all was good again until
now I've been living in this house for a
month and a half for the last three
weeks I've been seeing things everywhere
especially when I'm alone because of
this I won't stay alone anymore
I get this strong feeling of being
watched I had the feeling of someone
pulling on my blanket
I think it's time for another cleanse
and just for your information I'm the
third generation on my mother's side of
the family that is able to see spirits
my dad's side of the family has in the
past before I was born
practiced black magic I don't like
speaking to them and I won't dabble in
any of the spiritual stuff most people
do I say as far away from it as possible
and I recommend that you do too even if
you're careful these spirits can haunt
for a long time even after you are gone
[Music]
this happened in 2011 when I was a 7
year old girl I just talked to my mother
about this incident and decided to share
it
I lived with my grandmother father
mother and two dogs quite far from town
the house was big so I usually played
hide-and-seek with my mom a lot
I don't remember which month it was so
my mom filled me in on this she said it
was October during the holidays this one
particular day my dad was out driving my
grandma to the hospital as she had an
appointment with a doctor so I was left
alone with my mom after several rounds
of hide-and-seek and watching a movie
with my mom it began to get dark outside
and my dad still wasn't home I've always
been scared of potential home invasions
so I was paranoid all day because my dad
wasn't with us he made me feel very safe
me and my mom decided to play Monopoly
fast-forward an hour when I was 7 I
thought I was very sly so I kept
stealing money from my mom's stash now
that I look back she was probably
pretending not to see as I was taking a
$50 bill from her Monopoly cash she said
the power will go out soon this left me
completely puzzled as I had no idea how
she'd know this but sure enough it went
out about 15 minutes later and I started
to panic because as most little kids I'm
scared of the dark I later found out
that there was a power outage in my area
because of a storm and my mom was
notified of it she handed me this nokia
phone and let me play my favorite game
on it which at the time was doom she
told me to go hide under the bedsheets
if I was scared and that she would be
back soon I asked where she was going
but she didn't answer as she headed out
of the room she locked the door I lay
under the sheets killing some monsters
on the game for what felt like hours but
was probably only five minutes footsteps
were heard in the kitchen which was next
to the room I was in so I took the
sheets off my head and yelled out mom
glad that she was back because I was
really scared but no answer was heard
the footsteps didn't stop so I yelled
again mom can you please come I'm scared
after I had said that the footstep
stopped completely
I got a sudden rush of adrenaline so I
held tight onto the phone and dashed out
the room to the kitchen which was empty
I was left puzzled but didn't wait for
long as I ran to the door unlocked it as
there's keys on the inside - and ran to
the corridor so the corridor has four
doors on the right side one at the very
back which I never was allowed to go in
I later learned that the room was where
my great grandma died and no one had
touched it ever since it also had stairs
next to it leading to the second floor
and one at the front which led to the
outside the fourth door I came through
was the closest to the outside door so I
quickly opened the outside door ready to
run out but the rush of adrenaline was
gone and I got scared at the outside -
it was very dark and I was barely able
to see my only choices were go back to
the room I came from or scream for my
mother I chose number two and started
screaming for Mom over and over again I
guess I wasn't loud enough because there
were no replies I remember starting to
sweat and panic different scenarios
playing through my head scenarios like a
murderer killing my mom and coming for
me next
or my mom leaving me forever I know it's
stupid but I was only 7 after all I
remember looking down at my feet and
beginning to cry more footsteps were
heard but this time behind me I looked
behind me and saw a silhouette of a tall
person I'm assuming it's a male due to
the body build at the end of the hallway
standing in front of the door I can't
recall what he looked like because it
was all black I stared at him for about
15 seconds in pure horror this got my
adrenaline pumping again and I ran out
the door towards the outside toilet only
to be greeted by my mother who looked
too worried as hell after I told her
what happened through uncontrollable
sobs my dad was in the driveway already
parking his car my granny was left at
the hospital for some treatment he
searched the house but no one was found
so my mom told me it was just my
imagination but I know what I saw and
heard fast forward seven more years I
live in another house and I randomly
remembered about this incident and
talked to my mom about it
she seemed quite hesitant about telling
me this but in the end I convinced her
to tell me what she said gave me chills
apparently when I was four I started to
stare at one particular corner in the
kitchen and laugh like crazy my mom
asked me what was so funny and every
time I pointed to the same corner but
never told her why it was funny after a
few months the random giggles I let out
when staring at the corner didn't stop
what made my mom lose it was the fact
that I started speaking random German
words that I'd never heard before
we have no relatives that are German or
can speak German
and I wasn't introduced to technology at
that age either my mother knew it was
German because she can actually speak a
little but she never spoke it she bribed
me with candy to tell her how I learned
to say the following words in German it
helped chocolate shower and war my
response completely shocked her I
pointed to the same corner again and
said he taught me how my mom kept her
cool though she asked me who I was
talking about and I said the man who
makes me laugh my mom asked me what he
looked like but I only said he looks
like a shadow and that he's from Germany
when she asked where the man lived I
pointed to the second floor this all
made sense because I always hated the
second floor and never went up there
because I felt like I was being watched
my parents took it upon themselves to
Google the history of the house and sure
enough it was built by Germans I don't
remember any of this but my mom kept on
reassuring me it happened my father said
he remembers it too but decided not to
tell me until now I talked to the German
man in the corner up until five years of
age I'm pretty sure you can put two and
two together but if not the man I saw
when I was seven was the same man I
talked to when I was four every time I
go back to visit my grandma I always
feel uneasy
when I was eight years old my family
moved into the house I grew up in
it wasn't an old house and no one had
died in it it didn't even feel creepy
just an average suburban house in your
average southern suburbs the way the
house was set up when you came in the
front door there was a hallway with two
bedrooms and a bathroom to the right the
large living room in front of you with a
half wall separating it from the dining
room to the left and the kitchen on the
other side of the dining room were the
kitchen in the living room meant there
was another small hallway and the master
bedroom a bedroom that was used as an
office and a bathroom and then a
breakfast nook leading to a laundry and
utility area at the end of the kitchen
my room was to the right of the front
door and down the hallway past the
bathroom with the other bedroom on this
hallway used for storage mostly as I was
my mother's only child and my
half-brother and sister didn't live with
us and rarely came to visit the first
time anything really happened in the
house I was about nine and I'd lost my
last tooth still being a kid of course
the tooth fairy was expected so when I
woke up in the middle of the night and
saw a figure standing in the middle of
my room I assumed it was the tooth fairy
it was bald and only about three or four
feet tall about the size of an average
child standing completely still in the
middle of my room I remember my parents
telling me that if I was awake the Tooth
Fairy wouldn't leave me any money so I
rolled over and went back to sleep when
I got up the next morning I excitedly
told my parents that I'd seen the Tooth
Fairy the night before I described what
I had seen but they told me it was just
a dream for the next several years after
that I continued seeing and hearing
minor things in the house when I was
home alone cabinet doors would open and
close or I'd hear dishes being moved
around in the kitchen or catch movement
out of the corner of my eye the most
common was often at night I'd wake up to
see a young woman hovering over my bed
she was dressed like the Rosie the
Riveter character from the old posters
from the 1940s with the red and white
bandana around her hair and a denim
shirt when I would see her she'd stare
at me for a few minutes and then slowly
float over my body and out through the
wall behind me I was never afraid of her
though when I was about 12 my parents
divorced and it was just me and my
mother living in the house by the time I
was in my late teens my mother was
rarely at home and my house became the
hangout for me and my friends most
nights everyone gathering together to
play Dungeons and Dragons or something
similar after work one night we were
hanging out but didn't want to play so I
pulled out a Ouija board I picked up the
local toy store a few weeks before
wanted to try it out we sat in my room
to play with the lights out and the door
closed and it went pretty normally
nothing crazy happening for the most
part the only strange thing that
happened was at one point we asked
something like show yourself and at that
point we heard the front door open and
closed and heavy footsteps come down the
hall toward my room the handle of my
door started to turn and one of the guys
jumped up and locked the door before it
could open we didn't hear anything else
no footsteps moving away from the door
or anything and after a while we turned
on the light and opened the door to see
if my mother had come home unexpectedly
the house was empty and the front door
was locked we decided we'd had enough of
the game at that point put it up and
everyone went home a few weeks later we
were hanging out at my house again this
time playing Dungeons and Dragons though
one of the girls that usually came had
to work late and had classes in the
morning so she'd said she wouldn't be
coming while we were sitting in the
living room to play and around 2:00 in
the morning suddenly we heard footsteps
run across my wooden front porch it
sounded like someone very short or a
small child running quickly everyone in
the room heard it and we had a
conversation wondering if our friend had
changed her mind and had just arrived as
she was very short and it made more
sense than a child running through the
neighborhood at that time of night when
she never came into the house we all got
up to look and there was no one outside
and her car wasn't in the yard her
boyfriend who was with us gave her a
call and verified that it wasn't her as
she just arrived home on the other side
of town and was headed to bed
around this time the activity in the
house picked up
I saw shadow figures with red eyes often
in the living and dining room of the
house footsteps and other noises at all
hours of the day or night I started
waking up at my room to see hooded
figures standing near my window and door
it was around this time my half-brother
who I was close to passed away it was
sudden and I hadn't seen him in years as
he'd gotten into drugs and my mother had
decided to keep me away from him because
she didn't want him to be a bad
influence on me after that I'd wake up
hearing his voice saying my name in the
middle of the night often on a whim one
night I sat down and typed out a letter
to him on my computer that was in my
bedroom since I was home alone that
night and I was bored now this computer
was hooked up to an old dot-matrix
printer one of the really loud kind that
makes all kind of racket when it's
running after I wrote the letter I felt
silly for writing it and deleted it
without saving it or printing it and
shut down the computer before I went to
bed around 3:00 in the morning I woke up
and my bed was soaking wet at first I
thought my puppy had peed on the bed
because he was too small to get down
even though he was housebroken and I'd
taken him out just before bed I got up
to let him outside and change my bed
sheets when I realized that wet was just
water and it was more than a tiny puppy
could have made on my way to take my
blankets to the laundry room
I passed the bathroom in my hallway and
noticed the light was on even though I
turned off all the lights before bed
there sitting on the counter was a
picture from the kitchen with the inside
still wet when I was really young my
brother used to wake my sister and I up
by throwing water on us because it made
me laugh when I got back into my room
and started making my bed I noticed a
piece of paper lying on top of my
printer it was the letter that I'd
written to him and never saved her
printed the computer was still shut down
and the printer was off but it had been
printed out torn off the printer and
laid on top of it as if someone had read
it
the normal things like this continued
for a few years when I lived there off
and on
before turning dark shortly before I
moved out of the house for good the
hooded figures appeared more often I
woke up one night with a feeling that I
was being stared at only to roll over
and see what looked like a rotting
corpse a few inches from my face and one
night I woke up to a hooded man standing
at the foot of my bed with my bedroom
door open when it had been closed before
he held up his hand and a ball of blue
light appeared in his palm which he
threw at my face he and the ball
disappeared just before it hit me but
the room was so cold that I could see my
breath on a normally hot southern summer
night when I was in my early 20s after I
moved out for good I had one last
experience in the house my mother hadn't
been to the house in months and was
preparing to sell it I told one of my
cousin's about the things that had
happened there through the years and he
decided that one night out of boredom he
and a friend of his would pick me up to
go ghost hunting in the house while it
was empty we each had a camera and he
had a voice recorder that he'd brought
we set the recorder in my old bedroom
and spent an hour to wandering around
the house taking pictures when we got
done we came back to my room and sat to
listen to the recording and discuss all
of the nothing that we'd found on the
recording we could hear our voices
moving from room to room and talking
about how my cousin's friends camera had
a sexy shutter sound and the fact that
my camera stopped working almost as soon
as we walked in the door about 20
minutes into the recording when we could
hear all three of our voices echoing
from the other side of the house a deep
voice that sounded like it was right up
against the microphone on the recording
spoke get the [ __ ] out
we immediately obliged I found out a few
years later that my mom actually had
several experiences in that house with
waking up to find an older man in his
50s or 60s looking through her closet or
seeing him just wandering around the
house when she'd say anything to get his
attention he'd turn around and look at
her and then vanish she always thought
she was just dreaming or something but
with everything I saw over the years at
that house I can't help but think that
it was something else
[Music]
the hamlet of Trevor major lies very
lonely and sequestered in a hollow below
the north side of the South Downs that
stretch westward from lose and run
parallel with the coast it is a hamlet
of some three or four dozen in
considerable houses and cottages much
Girt about with trees but the big Norman
Church and the manor house which stands
a little outside the village are
evidence of a more conspicuous past this
latter except for a tendency of rather
less than three weeks now four years ago
has stood unoccupied since the summer of
1896 and though it could be taken at a
rent almost comically small it is highly
improbable that either of its last
tenants even if times were very bad
would think of passing a night in it
again for myself I was one of the
tenants I would far prefer living in a
workhouse to inhabiting those
low-pitched oak paneled rooms and I
would sooner look for my Garret windows
on to the squalor and grime of
Whitechapel than from the diamond-shaped
and leaded panes of the manor of Trevor
major on to the Bostitch of its cooled
thickets and the glimmering of it's
clear chalk stream where the quick trout
glanced among the waving water weeds and
over the chalk and gravel of its sliding
Rapids it was the news of these trout
that led Jack singleton and myself to
take the house for the month between
mid-may and mid-june but as I've already
mentioned a short three weeks was all
the time we passed there and we had more
than a week of our tenancy yet unexpired
when we left the place though on the
very last afternoon we enjoyed the
finest dry fly fishing that has ever
fallen to my lot singleton had
originally seen the advertisement of the
house in a Sussex paper with the
statement that there was good dry fly
fishing belonging to it but it was with
but faint hopes of the reality of the
dry fly fishing that we went down to
look at the place since we had before
this so often inspected depopulated
ditches which were offered to the unwary
under high sounding titles yet after a
half-hour stroll by the stream we went
straight back to the agent and before
nightfall had taken it for a month with
option of renewal
we arrived accordingly from town at
about five o'clock on a cloudless
afternoon in May and through the mists
of horror that now stand between me and
the remembrance of what occurred later I
cannot forget the exquisite loveliness
of the impression then conveyed the
garden it is true appeared to have been
for years untended weeds half choked the
gravel pass and the flowerbeds were a
congestion of mingled wild and
cultivated vegetations it was set in a
wall of mellowed brick in which
snapdragons and stonecrop had found an
anchorage to their liking and beyond
that there stood Sentinel a ring of
ancient pines in which the breeze made
music as of a distant sea outside that
the ground sloped slightly downwards in
a bank covered with a jungle of wild
rose to the stream that ran round three
sides of the garden and then followed a
meandering course through the two big
fields which late or de village over all
this we had fishing rights above the
same rights extended for another quarter
of a mile to the arched bridge over
which there crossed the road which led
to the house in this field above the
house on the fourth side where the
ground had been it banked to carry the
road stood a brick kiln in a ruinous
State a shallow pit long overgrown with
tall grasses and wildflowers showed
where the clay had been dug the house
itself was long and narrow entering you
past direct into a square paneled Hall
on the left of which was the dining room
which communicated with the passage
leading to the kitchen and offices on
the right of the hall were two excellent
sitting rooms looking out the one onto
the gravel in front of the house the
other onto the garden from the first of
these you could see through the gap in
the pines by which the road approached
the house the brick kiln of which I've
already spoken an oak staircase went up
from the hall and round it ran a gallery
onto which the three principal bedrooms
opened these were commensurate with the
dining-room and the two sitting rooms
below from this gallery there led a long
narrow passage shut off from the rest of
the house by a red baize door which led
to a couple more guest rooms and the
servants quarters
Jack singleton and I shared the same
flat in town and we had sent down in the
morning Franklin and his wife two old
and valued servants to get things ready
at trevor major and procure help from
the village to look after the house and
mrs. Franklin with her stout comfortable
face all wreathed in smiles open the
door to us she had had some previous
experience of the comfortable quarters
which go with fishing and had come down
prepared for the worst but found it all
of the best the kitchen boiler was not
furred hot and cold water was laid on in
the most convenient fashion and could be
obtained from taps that neither stuck
nor leaked her husband it appeared had
gone into the village to buy a few
necessaries and she brought up tea for
us and then went upstairs to the two
rooms over the dining room in the bigger
sitting-room which we had chosen for our
bedrooms to unpack the doors of these
were exactly opposite one another to
right and left of the gallery and Jack
who chose the bedroom above the
sitting-room had thus a smaller room
above the second sitting-room unoccupied
next to his and opening out from it we
had a couple of hours fishing before
dinner each of us catching three or four
brace of trout and came back in the dusk
to the house Franklin had returned from
the village from his errand reported
that he had got a woman to come in to do
housework in the mornings and mentioned
that our arrival had seemed to arouse a
good deal of interest the reason for
this was obscure he can only tell us
that he was questioned a dozen times as
to whether we really intended to live in
the house and his assurance that we did
produce silence and a shaking of heads
but the country folk of Sussex are
notable for their silence and chronic
attitude of disapproval so we put this
down to local idiosyncrasy the evening
was exquisitely warm and after dinner we
pulled out a couple of basket chairs
onto the gravel by the front door and
sat for an hour or so while the night
deepened in throbs of gathering darkness
the moon was not risen and the ring of
pines cut off much of the pale starlight
so that when we went in allured by the
shining of the lamp in the sitting-room
it was curiously dark for a clear night
in May
and at that moment of stepping from the
darkness into the cheerfulness of the
lighted house I had a sudden sensation
to which during the next fortnight I
became almost accustomed of there being
something unseen and unheard and
dreadful near me in spite of the warmth
I felt myself shiver and concluded
instantly that I had sat out of doors
long enough and without mentioning it to
Jack followed him into the smaller
sitting-room in which we had scarcely
yet set foot it like the hall was open
old and in the panel's hung some
half-dozen of watercolor sketches which
we examined idly at first and then with
growing interest for they were executed
with extraordinary finish in delicacy
and each represented some aspect of the
house or garden here you looked up the
gap in the fir trees into a crimson
sunset here the garden trim and
carefully tended doze beneath some
languid summer noon here an angry wreath
of storm cloud brooded over the meadow
where the trout stream ran gray and
leaden below a threatening sky while
another the most careful and arresting
of all was a study of the brick kiln in
this alone of them all was there a human
figure a man dressed in grey peered into
the open door from which issued a fierce
red glow the figure was painted with
miniature like elaboration the face was
in profile and represented a youngish
man clean-shaven with a long aqualen
nose and singularly square chin the
sketch was long and narrow in shape and
the chimney of the kiln appeared against
a dark sky from it there issued a thin
stream of gray smoke Jack looked at this
with attention what a horrible picture
he said and how beautifully painted I
feel as if it meant something as if it
was a representation of something that
happened not a mere sketch by Jove he
broke off suddenly and when in turn two
each of the other pictures that's a
queer thing he said see if he noticed
what I mean with the brick kiln rather
vividly impressed on my mind it was not
difficult to see what he had noticed in
each of the pictures appeared the brick
kiln chimney and all now seen faintly
between trees now in full view and in
each the chimney
smoking and the odd part is that from
the garden side you can't really see the
kill at all observe Jack it's hidden by
the house and yet the artist FA as I see
by a signature puts it in just the same
what do you make of that
I asked nothing I suppose he had a fancy
for brick kilns a fortnight of our three
weeks passed without incident except it
again and again the curious feeling of
something dreadful being close at hand
was present in my mind in a way as I
said I got used to it but on the other
hand the feeling itself seemed to gain
in poignancy once just at the end of the
fortnight I mentioned it to Jack odd you
should speak of it he said because I
felt the same when do you feel it do you
feel it now for instance we were again
sitting out after dinner and as he spoke
I felt it with far greater intensity
than ever before and at the same moment
the house door which had been closed
though probably not latched swung gently
open letting out a shaft of light from
the hall and as gently swung to again as
if something had stealthily entered yes
I said I felt it then I only feel it in
the evening it was rather bad that time
jack was silent for a moment
funny thing the door opening and
shutting like that he said let's go
indoors we got up and I remember seeing
at that moment that the windows of my
bedroom were lit mrs. Franklin probably
was making things ready for the night
simultaneously as we crossed the gravel
there came from just inside the house
the sound of a hurried footsteps on the
stairs and entering we found mrs.
Franklin in the hall looking rather
white and startled anything wrong I
asked she took two or three quick
breaths before she answered no sir she
said at least nothing that I can give an
account of I was tidying up in your room
and I thought you came in but there was
nobody and it gave me a turn I left my
candle there I must go up for it
I waited in the hall a moment while she
again ascended the stairs and passed
along the gallery to my room at the door
which I could see was open she paused
not entering what's the matter I asked
from below
I left the candle alight she said and
it's gone out jack laughed and you left
the door and window open said he yes sir
but not a breath of wind is stirring
said mrs. Franklin rather faintly this
was true
and yet a few moments ago the heavy Hall
door had swung open and back again Jack
ran upstairs will brave the dark
together mrs. Franklin he said he went
into my room and I heard the sound of a
match struck then through the open door
came the light of the rekindled candle
and simultaneously I heard a bell ring
in the servants quarters in a moment
came steps and Franklin appeared what
bell was that I asked mr. Jack's bedroom
sir he said I felt there was a market
atmosphere of nerves about for which
there was really no adequate cause all
that had happened of a disturbing nature
was that mrs. Franklin had thought I had
come into my bedroom and had then been
startled by finding I had not she had
then left the candle in a draught and it
had been blown out as for the bell
ringing that even if it had happened was
a very innocuous proceeding mouse on a
wire I said mr. Jack is in my room this
moment lighting mrs. Franklin's candle
for her Jack came down at this juncture
and we went into the sitting-room but
Franklin apparently was not satisfied
for we heard him in the room above us
which was Jack's bedroom moving about
with his slow and rather ponderous tread
then his steps seemed to pass into the
bedroom adjoining and we heard no more
I remember feeling hugely sleepy that
night and we went to bed earlier than
usual to pass rather a broken night with
stretches of dreamless sleep
interspersed with startled awakenings in
which I passed very suddenly into
complete consciousness sometimes the
house was absolutely still and the only
sound to be heard was the sighing of the
night breeze outside in the pines but
sometimes the place seemed full of
muffled movements and once I could have
sworn that the handle of my door turned
that required verification and I lit my
candle but found that my ears must have
played me false yet even as I stood
there I thought I heard steps just
outside and with a considerable qualms I
must confess I opened the door and
looked out but the gallery was quite
empty and the house quite still
then from Jack's room opposite I heard a
sound that was somehow comforting the
snorts of the snorer and I went back to
bed and slept again and when next I woke
morning was already breaking in red
lines on the horizon and the sense of
trouble that had been with me ever since
last evening had gone heavy rain set in
after lunch next day and as I had a
rears of letter-writing to do and the
water was soon both muddy and rising I
came home alone about 5:00 leaving
Jack's still sanguine by the stream and
worked for a couple of hours sitting at
a writing table in the room overlooking
the gravel at the front of the house
where hung the watercolors by seven I
had finished and just as I got up to
light candles since it was already dusk
I saw as I thought Jack's figure emerged
from the bushes that bordered the path
to the stream onto the space in front of
the house then instantaneously and with
a sudden queer sinking of the heart
quite unaccountable I saw that it was
not Jack at all but a stranger he was
only some six yards from the window and
after pausing there a moment he came
close up to the window so that his face
nearly touched the glass looking
intently at me in the light from the
freshly kindled candles I could
distinguish his features with great
clearness but though as far as I knew I
had never seen him before it was
something familiar about both his face
and figure he appeared to smile at me
but the smile was one of inscrutable
evil and malevolence and immediately he
walked on straight towards the house
door opposite him and out of sight of
the sitting-room window now little
though I liked the look of the man he
was as I have said familiar to my eye
and I went out into the hall since he
was clearly coming to the front door to
open it to him and learn his business so
without waiting for him to ring I opened
it feeling sure I should find him on the
step
instead I looked out into the empty
gravel sweep the heavy falling rain the
thick dusk and even as I looked I felt
something that I could not see push by
me through the half-open door and pass
into the house then the stairs creaked
and a moment after a bell rang Franklin
is the quickest man to answer a bell I
have ever seen and next instant he
passed me going up stairs he tapped at
Jack's door entered and then came down
again mr. Jack's still out sir he asked
yes
his bell ringing again yes sir said
Franklin quite imperturbable
I went back into the sitting-room and
soon Franklin brought a lamp he put it
on the table above which hung the
careful and curious picture of the brick
kiln and then with a sudden horror I saw
why the stranger on the gravel outside
had been so familiar to me in all
respects he resembled the figure that
peered into the kiln it was more than a
resemblance it was an identity and what
had happened to this man who had
inscrutably and evilly smiled at me and
what had pushed in through the half
closed door at that moment I saw the
face of fear my mouth went dry and I
heard my heart leaping and cracking in
my throat that face was only turned on
me for a moment and then away again but
I knew it to be the genuine thing not
apprehension not foreboding not a
feeling of being startled but fear cold
fear and then though nothing had
occurred to assuage the fear it passed
and a certain sort of reason usurped its
place I had certainly seen somebody on
the gravel outside the house I had
supposed he was going to the front door
I had opened it and found he had not
come to the front door or and once again
the terror researched had the invisible
pushing thing been that which I had seen
outside and if so what was it and how
came it that the face and figure of the
man I had seen were the same as those
which were so scrupulously painted in
the picture of the brick helm
I set myself to argue down the fear for
which there was no more foundation than
this this and the repetition of the
ringing Bell and my belief is that I did
so I told myself till I believed it that
a man a human man had been walking
across the gravel outside and that he
had not come to the front door but had
gone as he might easily have done up to
drive into the high road I told myself
that it was mere fancy that was the
cause of the belief that something had
pushed in by me and as for the ringing
of the Bell I said to myself as was true
that this had happened before and I must
ask the reader to believe also that I
argued these things away and looked no
longer in the face of fear itself I was
not comfortable but I fell short of
being terrified i sat down again by the
window looking onto the gravel in front
of the house and finding another letter
that asked though it did not demand an
answer proceeded to occupy myself with
it straight in front led the drive
through the gap in the pines and passed
through the field where lay the brick
kiln in a pause of page turning I looked
up and saw something unusual about it at
the same moment an unusual smell came to
my nostril when I saw was smoke coming
out of the chimney of the kiln what I
smelt was the odor of roasting meat the
wind such as there was set from the
kilns of the house but as far as I knew
the smell of roast meat probably came
from the kitchen where dinner so I
supposed was cooking I had to tell
myself this I wanted reassurance lest
the face of fear should look white lay
on me again then there came a crisp step
on the gravel a rattle at the front door
and Jack came in good sport he said you
gave up too soon and he went straight to
the table above which hung the picture
of the man at the brick kiln and looked
at it then there was silence and
eventually I spoke for I wanted to know
one thing seen anybody I asked yes why
do you ask because I have also the man
in that picture Jack came and sat down
near me it's a ghost you know he said he
came down to the river about dusk and
stood near me for an hour
at first I thought he was real and I
warned him that he had better stand
further off if he didn't want to be
hooked and then it struck me he wasn't
real and I cast well right through him
and about seven he walked up towards the
house were you frightened no it was so
tremendously interesting so you saw him
here too whereabouts
just outside I think he is in the house
now
Jack looked round did you see him come
in he asked no but I felt him there's
another queer thing to the chimney of
the brick kiln is smoking Jack looked
out of the window it was nearly dark but
the reefing smoke could just be seen so
it is he said fat greasy smoke I think
I'll go up and see what's on come too I
think not I said are you frightened
it isn't worthwhile besides it is so
tremendously interesting Jack came back
from his little expedition still
interested he had found nothing stirring
at the kiln but though it was then
nearly dark the interior was faintly
luminous
and against the black of the sky he
could see a wisp of thick white smoke
floating northwards but for the rest of
the evening we neither heard nor saw
anything of abnormal import and the next
day ran a course of undisturbed hours
then suddenly a hellish activity was
manifested that night while I was
undressing for bed I heard a bell ring
furiously and I thought I heard a shout
also I guessed where the ring came from
since Franklin and his wife had long ago
gone to bed and went straight to Jack's
room but as I tapped at the door I heard
his voice from inside calling loud to me
take care it said he's close to the door
a sudden qualm of blank fear took hold
of me but mastering it as best I could I
opened the door to enter and once again
something pushed softly by me though I
saw nothing Jack was standing by his bed
half undressed
I saw him wipe his forehead with the
back of his hand
he's been here again he said I was
standing just here a minute ago when I
found him close by me he came out of the
inner room I think did you see what he
had in his hand I saw nothing it was a
knife a great long carving knife do you
mind my sleeping on the sofa in your
room tonight I got an awful turn then
there was another thing too around the
edge of his clothes and his collar and
at his wrists there were little flames
playing little white licking flames but
next day again we neither heard nor saw
anything nor that night did the sense of
that dreadful presence in the house come
to us and then came the last day we had
been out till it was dark and as I said
had a wonderful day among the fish on
reaching home we sat together in the
sitting room when suddenly from overhead
came a tread of feet a violent peeling
of the Bell and the moment after yell
after yell as if someone in mortal agony
the thought occurred to both of us that
this might be mrs. Franklin and terror
of some fearful sight and together we
brushed up and sprang into Jack's
bedroom the doorway into the room beyond
was open and just inside it we saw the
man bending over some dark huddled
object though the room was dark we could
see him perfectly for a light stale and
impure seemed to come from him he had
again a long knife in his hand and as we
entered he was wiping it on the mass
that lay at his feet then he took it up
and we saw that it was a woman with head
nearly severed but it was not mrs.
Franklin and then the whole thing
vanished and we were standing looking
into a dark and empty room we went
downstairs without a word and it was not
till we were both in the sitting-room
below that Jack spoke and he takes her
to the brick kiln he said rather
unsteadily I say have you had enough of
this house I have there's hell in it
about a week later Jack put into my hand
a guidebook to Sussex open at the
description of trevor major and i read
just outside the village stands the
picturesque manor house once the home of
the artist and notorious murderer
Frances Adam it was here he killed his
wife in a fit it is believed of
groundless jealousy cutting her throat
and disposing of her remains by burning
them in a brick kiln certain charred
fragments found six months afterwards
led to his arrest and execution so I
prefer to leave the house with the brick
kiln and the picture signed FA to others
[Laughter]
he was waiting for her he had been
waiting an hour and a half in a dusty
suburban Lane with a row of big Elms on
one side and some eligible building
sites on the other and far away to the
southwest the twinkling yellow lights of
the Crystal Palace it was not quite like
a country lane for it had a pavement and
lampposts but it was not a bad place for
a meeting all the same and farther up
towards the cemetery it was really quite
rural and almost pretty especially in
Twilight the Twilight had long deepened
into night and still he waited he loved
her and he was engaged to be married to
her with the complete disapproval of
every reasonable person who had been
consulted and this half clandestine
meeting was tonight to take the place of
the grudgingly sanctioned weekly
interview because a certain rich uncle
was visiting at her house and her mother
was not the woman to acknowledge to a
moneyed uncle who might go off any day a
match so deeply ineligible as hers with
him so he waited for her and the chill
of an unusually severe May evening
entered into his bones
the policeman passed him with but a
surly response to his goodnight the
bicyclists went by him like grey ghosts
with fog horns and it was nearly ten
o'clock and she had not come
he shrugged his shoulders and turned
towards his lodgings his road led him by
her house desirable commodious
semi-detached and he walked slowly as he
neared it she might even now be coming
out but she was not there was no sign of
movement about the house no sign of life
no lights even in the windows and her
people were not early people he paused
by the gate wondering then he noticed
that the front door was open wide open
and the street lamps shone a little way
into the dark hall there was something
about all this that did not please him
that scared him a little indeed the
house had a gloomy and deserted air it
was obviously impossible that it
harbored a rich uncle the old man must
have left early in which case he walked
up the path of Patten glazed tiles and
listened no sign of life he passed into
the hall there was no light anywhere
where was everybody and why was the
front door open there was no one in the
drawing-room the dining room in the
study nine feet by seven were equally
blank everyone was out evidently but the
unpleasant sense that he was perhaps not
the first casual visitor to walk through
that open door impelled him to look
through the house before he went away
and closed it after him so he went
upstairs and at the door of the first
bedroom he came to he struck a wax match
as he had done in the sitting rooms even
as he did so he felt that he was not
alone and he was prepared to see
something but for what he saw he was not
prepared for what he saw lay on the bed
in a white loose gown and it was his
sweetheart and its throat was cut from
ear to ear he doesn't know what happened
then nor how he got downstairs and into
the street but he got out somehow and
the policeman found him in a fit under
the lamppost at the corner of the street
he couldn't speak when they picked him
up and he passed the night in the police
cells because the policeman had seen
plenty of drunken men before but never
one in a fit
the next morning he was better though
still very white and shaky but the tale
he told the magistrate was convincing
and they sent a couple of constables
with him to her house there was no crowd
about it as he fancied there would be
and the blinds were not down as he stood
dazed in front of the door it opened and
she came out he held on to the doorpost
for support she's all right you see said
the constable who had found him under
the lamp I told you you was drunk but
you would know best when he was alone
with her he told her not all for that
would not bear telling but how he had
come into the commodious semi-detached
and how he had found the door open and
the lights out and that he had been into
that long back room facing the stairs
and had seen something in even trying to
hint at which he turned sick and broke
down and had to have brandy given to him
but my dearest she said I dare say the
house was dark for we were all at the
Crystal Palace with my uncle and no
doubt the door was open for the maids
will run out if their left but you could
not have been in that room because I
locked it when I came away and the key
was in my pocket I dressed in a hurry
and I left all my odds and ends lying
about I know he said I saw a green scarf
on a chair and some long brown gloves
and a lot of hairpins and ribbons and a
prayer-book and a lace handkerchief on
the dressing table why I even noticed
the Almanac on the mantelpiece October
21st
at least it couldn't be that because
this is May and yet it was your Almanac
is at October 21st isn't it
no of course it isn't she said smiling
rather anxiously but all the other
things were just as you say you must
have had a dream or a vision or
something
he was a very ordinary commonplace City
young man and he didn't believe in
visions but he never rested day or night
till he got his sweetheart and her
mother away from that commodious
semi-detached and settled them in a
quite distant suburb in the course of
the removal he incidentally married her
and the mother went on living with them
his nerves must have been a good bit
shaken because he was very queer for a
long time and was always inquiring if
anyone had taken the desirable
semi-detached and when an old
stockbroker with a family took it he
went the length of calling on the old
gentleman and imploring him by all that
he held dear not to live in that fatal
house why said the stockbroker not
unnaturally and then he got so vague and
confused between trying to tell why and
trying not to tell why that the
stockbroker showed him out and thanked
his God he was not such a fool as to
allow a lunatic to stand in the way of
his taking that really remarkably cheap
and desirable semi-detached residence
now the curious and quite an explicable
part of this story is that when she came
down to breakfast on the morning of the
22nd of October she found him looking
like death with the morning paper in his
hand he caught hers he couldn't speak
and pointed to the paper and there she
read that on the night of the 21st a
young lady
the stockbrokers daughter had been found
with her throat cut from ear to ear on
the bed in the long back bedroom facing
the stairs of that desirable
semi-detached
[Music]
you
you